but I don't I just look so bad
[Music]
are they edible things that you put in
the juicer
I really I'm really mad at you right now
pancake
looks like pancake batter is not so bad
no no I don't like it but I thought it
was gonna be something that would make
me yeah you bastard
look at my hands you can juice it it or
inspires it what does everyone else get
top layers piss the bottom layer is poop
this is like like matcha
[Music]
Machado that's it was that all Greece
but this looking stuff that just grieves
the smell
my guess is a McDonald's apple pie it
tastes like cinnamon and Apple it tastes
like an apple pie I don't love apple
pies it's like a cinnamon apple protein
shake that's it there's no Apple in it
there's no Apple how weird guess I'm
just so used to associating cinnamon
with apple again why would you write
because usually people juice things that
taste bad so they can just get it done
with one go but yeah I mean it's not
revolting a regular cinnamon roll to a
rip some cinnamon rolls I think it's
something gross man I think it's like
saliva baby saliva it's peanut butter
saliva if I say that I'm allergic to
peanuts do I still have to do this no it
tastes like watered-down like peanut
shows there's no sweetness to it it is
it tastes like tastes like cardboard
it's a Snickers okay it's a juiced
Snickers it would be solid
you don't juice the Snickers oh no
should not be juice I thought you were
gonna have me drink [ __ ] honestly
when I came in here and I was like I'm a
fighter I'm a fighter
I already know what it is
Hot Cheetos it's hot cheetos juice this
smell is undeniable have I ever wished
it was in beverage form now oh there's
like a layer of grease on top yeah those
are hot cheetos two things that make hot
cheetos good the heat and the texture
and there's no texture with this you're
missing that crunch no no some things
are left best left on juiced no I'm not
surprised cuz you're sick yeah I do
resent you for this
[Music]
yeah